it's chewy stretchy and so delicious
mochi is a sweet or savory rice cake
that's been enjoyed for centuries you
may have had it filled with ice cream
red bean or on its own as a topping
today we're going to show you how to
make daifuku which is just a variation
of mochi that has a sweet filling inside
there are a ton of varieties but we'll
be stuffing ours with three of the most
common fillings red bean paste
strawberries and matcha ice cream okay
time to make some mochi magic
mochi is made from a glutinous rice
called mochigome which is steamed and
then pounded into the smooth chewy
consistency traditionally in japan the
rice is first soaked in water and then
steamed in boxes called seido the
steamed rice is then transferred to a
mortar known as usu and pounded with
huden mallets called kinet a rhythm
forms amongst those pounding the mochi
and the person turning and wetting the
mochi once the pounding is complete the
mochi is ready to be shaped
we know not everyone has gigantic
mallets at home so today we're going to
show you how to make mochi using a sweet
and super easy mochi base called yuhi to
make yuhi we'll need mochiko a sweet
rice flour mochiko is made out of the
same glutinous rice that gives mochi its
amazing texture we'll start by mixing
together our mochiko sugar and water and
a microwave-safe bowl until the mixture
is smooth
to color our strawberry daifuku mochi
pink we're going to add a teaspoon of
dragon fruit powder to the mixture
and to color our matcha ice cream
daifuku green we'll add a teaspoon of
matcha powder
cover the bowl with plastic wrap and
microwave it in 60 second intervals
we're cooking our mochi mixture and a
microwave but you can also use a
stovetop rice cooker or steamer the
mixture should look halfway transparent
like this give it a quick mix cover it
again and then pop it back in the
microwave for 15 to 30 second intervals
and make sure to keep stirring in
between we really want to be careful not
to burn our mochi mixture you'll know
when it's ready when it's super glossy
like this cover your work surface and
cornstarch and pour the mochi mixture
out it's going to be super hot so just
let it sit for a minute to cool down
mochi dough is super sticky so it's
really important that you also dust the
mochi and your hands with cornstarch
next we'll roll out the dough using a
rolling pin until it's half an inch
thick then we'll use a pizza cutter to
cut out 3 by three inch mochi dough
squares you should have four squares per
color
okay let's get into our beautiful
fillings the first filling we're going
to make is red bean paste you can buy
pre-made paste in grocery stores but we
like to make it from scratch to control
its moisture levels
first we'll rinse half a cup of red
beans under cold water we love adzuki
beans from hokkaido because they're
smaller and a bit more tender than the
other kinds then we'll add the beans and
one and a quarter cups of water to a
rice cooker and cook for about an hour
and a half the beans should still be
firm like this we'll rinse the beans one
more time and put them back in the rice
cooker with another half cup of water
we'll cook the bean mixture again for an
hour and a half until the beans are
super tender and cooked through
we'll sweeten it up with some sugar and
salt
and just let it sit in the rice cooker
one last time for about 30 minutes
then we'll mash everything together and
spread the paste onto a small baking
tray to let it cool down you want it to
feel pliable and not too firm like
play-doh if it's too dry refrigerate it
for at least two hours or up to
overnight if it's too wet microwave it
in 90 second intervals until the water
has evaporated cover the red bean paste
with plastic wrap and let it cool to
room temperature we'll use some of this
for our red bean daifuku and some for
our strawberry daifuku to prepare
strawberry daifuku filling we'll cover
four strawberries and red bean paste
start by rolling the red bean paste into
a small ball and then flattening it into
a disc then bring in your beautiful
strawberry and work the red bean paste
from the top down to the bottom of it
like this for fruit filled mochi it's
best to pick ripened delicious fruits
such as strawberries pineapples and
kiwis strawberries are the best for
beginners because they're not as watery
and they hold up their shape well now
we'll cover these and let them chill in
the fridge while we prepare our matcha
ice cream filling preparing your filling
for ice cream mochi is really simple
it's crucial that your ice cream is
super cold so it doesn't melt while
you're trying to wrap it that can get
messy trust me
our trick for this is scooping out the
ice cream in advance and freezing it for
at least an hour to let it really harden
now we're ready to put these cute mochi
babies together we'll start with our red
bean daifuku place one of the mochi
squares in your palm and add two
tablespoons of red bean paste in the
center bring the edges of the dough up
and over to seal like this make sure
your fingers are adequately dusted with
cornstarch so the mochi doesn't stick
blot the seam side down on the dusted
surface and trim off any excess mochi
you can save the extra pieces for a
well-deserved snack now or later that
was easy right let's do it again with
our strawberries for a strawberry
daifuku we'll wrap our strawberries in
our gorgeous pink mochi using the same
technique place a pink square of mochi
in your hand and place a wrapped
strawberry in the center of the mochi
the bottom tip should be pointing down
like this now bring the edges of the
dough up and over to seal like we did
last time again we'll blot the sticky
side on the dusty surface okay i promise
you this will all be worth it now it's
time for a delicious matcha ice cream
daifuku place one of the green mochi
squares in the palm of your hand and
drop a scoop of ice cream in the center
our ice cream is now cold and hard and
much easier to work with connect the
four seams with your other hand and once
it's wrapped up blot the sticky part
again
make sure to set your mochi seam side
down
now we finally get to eat them and
you'll want to eat them right away
because nothing compares to chewy
delicious texture of fresh mochi
whether it's a red bean strawberry or
matcha ice cream filled daifuku we
guarantee each of your cute creations
will be delicious you can package them
in little cupcake holders and give them
as gifts or you can have a little mochi
party and eat them with your family and
friends you can find the recipes for all
three daifuku's on tasty.com we really
hope you love this as mochi as we do
oh yes
[Music]
you